hi there steve kaufman
here and today i want to talk about
english all right the
most widely studied language in the
world the largest number of second
language speakers
uh it's become the international
language of communication and and
business and even science so
lots of people learning english
and i think lots of people are
sort of stuck at a level in english
where they would like to improve
or that they don't feel satisfied with
their level in english and they don't
know how to go about improving
so
um we have um
a new employee anna and i did a video a
week ago
with anna and she's taking part in a
90-day challenge to work on her english
and so i had a session with her
yesterday where i went over three
bits of advice three tips
on things that she can do to improve our
english
uh i don't know if
if these will be these tips will prove
useful or not but i thought i would
share them with you as well
all right
um so i said to anna and maybe anna is
typical of a lot of people her
background is in digital marketing in
spain she's going to help us uh we went
we um the day before yesterday we had a
session three four hours we talked about
you know what's known as onboarding and
how you know at link we can
try to do things that might make people
want to join link more than what's
happening right now on the site so that
was the nature of the meeting she
participated she participated
effectively
but i came away with the sense that
there are three areas where she could
improve and i think these these three
areas apply to other people so first of
all i said to her
number one is comprehension
uh there are moments when i can tell
that she doesn't fully understand what
we're saying
or she has to ask for clarification
and so i said you know comprehension is
more important
than
your ability to say things sort of
totally without error fluently
if you are looking for words or if you
have to go back and say it twice because
we didn't fully understand what you said
that's less of a problem than when you
don't understand because you can control
what you're saying you can see that
people didn't fully understand you can
say it again
but if you don't understand if you
understand 85 but you're missing 15
very often that's a very important 15
and you just can't keep on asking soria
but your partner didn't understand so
you have to focus first of all on
comprehension
and therefore i recommended that she
should have three kinds of content that
she listens to and reads and that she
works on in link
number one is her professional content
so this is sometimes you have these
courses business english or whatever
academic english
go find
content in your area of professional you
know specialization expertise
import these into link study the words
the phrases get all the key terminology
as well as you know the phrasing that
helps you introduce your thoughts and
you can glean these from
this professional
material so that's the first kind of
content that she should work on to
improve her comprehension
the second is because i believe that a
lot of language learning is connected
with emotion
go and find
some content it might be literature
something that you can
really like and connect with on an
emotional level
could be a novel could be anything and
and i recommend that you have both
the ebook so that you can read it and
pick up words and increase your
vocabulary and the audio that you can
listen to and take yourself into another
world but you're totally relying on
english in this case for her
to take you there so you're building
sort of a a
sentimental connection to the language
you're learning i have always found that
that was important in my learning i
can't you can't just focus on the
professional terminology you kind of
have to elevate your total level in the
language that's been my experience so i
said to her so do one your professional
content two some content that you can
fall in love with and three work the
many stories that we have because there
you have all the basic structures all of
the most frequently used words and you
can listen to it over and over again you
can listen to it mechanically in the
background while you're exercising and
the many stories is more like going to
the gym in fact it's just exercising in
some of the more basic structures in the
language okay so i said do these three
things
then that's going to help you in the
second major point so the first point
was comprehension the second point is
pronunciation
now she pronounces well enough that we
understand
and and in a way that's the only thing
that really matters
but most people want to pronounce better
than that
and so
the first thing i pointed out to her is
that you have to divorce the way words
are said from the way they are written
in spanish there's a direct connection
between how words are written and how
they're pronounced that's not the case
in english and while people know that at
some theoretical level they don't
necessarily apply it and so she was
saying things like answer instead of
answer
and so i pointed out you know for
example answer
uh she would say she might say turn and
burn
but then when it comes to learn
because it's l-e-a-r-n
she would say learn and i had to again i
say focus on the fact that the
the writing system doesn't match the way
words are pronounced that was one thing
the second thing i said is focus on
intonation
if you can get the intonation of the
language a lot of this other stuff will
fall into place even your phrasing will
fall into place
and so i recommended that she again go
on link take a paragraph
begin by doing five second bursts
because we can control the sound bar
repeat five seconds and in that five
seconds don't worry about what you
mispronounce as an individual word but
try to get the intonation of that five
second
bit then do it for a sentence and then
do it for a whole paragraph and work on
that for let's say 15 minutes just
totally focusing on intonation
then go and record yourself and compare
yourself to
the native speaker don't do it every
time you know work on on getting
yourself up to a certain level then
compare you might be disappointed but if
you do that every day for two weeks you
will start to get closer to the
intonation
it's not a matter of eliminating all
evidence of a foreign accent that's not
possible it's not even desirable in fact
a slight spanish accent or french or
whatever it might be is attractive in
many ways if other things are there like
perhaps intonation
because it shows that you are trying to
pronounce you're making an effort to
approach the language you're learning or
to approach english so to work on
intonation and three reminded her again
that unlike spanish
you know in english the unstressed
syllable the vowel often disappears we
don't say important we say important
uh you know comprehend we don't say
comprehension we say comprehension so
that sometimes called the schwa but why
introduce new terms
unstressed syllable the vowel disappears
just be aware of it notice it slowly
hopefully that becomes part of your
pronunciation so that was the second
point on pronunciation and the third
point is
phrasing
she has a lot of words uh she can always
find more words i mean we come across
words that she hasn't heard before one
can always increase one's vocabulary but
like many people she's making up the
language as she goes along finding the
words often from her own language
translating some words and putting them
together
uh you know
and therefore delivering
sort of an english
structure
that is based on spanish patterns so you
have to
work on getting
english phrasing english patterns
there again i said that's why you should
work on the mini stories because it's
simple content there's not many words
there that you don't know it's everyday
situations a lot of repetition and just
focus on the phrasing
when you listen and read focus on
phrases
then try use those try to use those
phrases so that
the goal in the listening and reading is
to identify phrases save them on link if
you're in link so that when you go to
speak you're now able to speak in in
ready-made pre-fabricated phrases that
are in fact
english phrases rather than having to
take one word and another word and
combine them in some way that
corresponds to perhaps spanish structure
and therefore sounds clumsy in english
if you can have
good comprehension
if your pronunciation has
more
of a
native intonation in english and if
you're able to use more
natural phrasing and again we're not
talking about perfection here but as a
direction to move into better
comprehension better intonation and
better phrasing
then your english will improve so i look
forward to your comments and this
applies of course to any language but
particularly to english where so many
people are at sort of an intermediate
level where they would like to make a
breakthrough to a higher level
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you